♪ ♪
>> Laura: WE'VE LONG TOLD YOU
ABOUT ACTIVIST JUDGES
UNDERMINING TRUMP'S IMMIGRATION
POLICIES, BUT THIS NEXT STORY IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
A DISTRICT COURT JUDGE IN
MASSACHUSETTS IS ACCUSED OF
HELPING AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
SNAKE OUT A BACKDOOR TO AVOID
BEING DEPORTED.
[LAUGHS]
HERE'S THE BACK STORY.
JOSE MEDINA PEREZ OF THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC WAS IN COURT
ON DRUG CHARGES AND ALSO
FACED A FUGITIVE WARRANT FOR
DRUNK DRIVING.
IN A NEW AUDIO RECORDING
OBTAINED BY "THE BOSTON GLOBE" "
HIS DEFENSE ATTORNEY IS HEARD AT
THE BENCH WITH THE PROSECUTOR.
JUDGE SHELLEY JOSEPH, THEY
RAISED DOUBT ABOUT WHETHER
MEDINA-PEREZ HAD BEEN CORRECTLY
IDENTIFIED BY I.C.E. AND WHETHER
HE SHOULD BE SET FREE.
LISTEN.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S HIM.
>> [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
>> Laura: NO MINUTES AFTER
THAT RECORDING, WITNESSES SAY
THE ILLEGAL WAS ESCORTED OUT
A BACK DOOR AND THEN RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY.
HE THEN SCALED A FENCE AND
ESCAPED.
WE SHOULD NOTE HE HAS NOT BEEN
CAUGHT.
JOINING ME NOW, LEO TERREL,
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY AND BRIAN
CALLEY, A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR IN MASSACHUSETTS.
BRIAN, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
HOW UNIQUE IS IT TO HAVE A
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION INTO A
SITTING STATE COURT JUDGE ON AN
ISSUE SUCH AS THIS?
>> IT'S NOT COMMON AT ALL,
LAURA.
IT'S A BIZARRE SET OF FACTS,
RIGHT?
THE DEFENDANT IS ARRESTED ON
DRUG CHARGES, HE'S BEEN DEPORTED
TWICE BEFORE, AND THEN BECAUSE,
FOR WHATEVER REASON, THE JUDGE
TURNS OFF THE TAPE RECORDER,
CONTRARY TO COURT RULES, WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT SHE SAYS
NEXT, THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
HE'S RUNNING OUT THE BACK DOOR
INTO THE STREETS OF BOSTON.
I THINK EVEN BY MASSACHUSETTS
STANDARDS, THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH JUDICIAL ACTIVISM, AND
IT HAS LIED TO, ACCORDING TO
"THE BOSTON GLOBE," A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
A GRAND JURY INVESTIGATION.
THAT COME IN AND OF ITSELF, IS
QUITE UNUSUAL.
>> Laura: HE HAS SINCE BEEN
CAUGHT, I WANT TO MAKE SURE I
GET THIS RIGHT.
HE HAS SINCE BEEN CAUGHT.
THE UNDERLYING FACTS OF THIS ARE
REALLY DISTURBING.
GOVERNOR CHARLIE BAKER SPOKE OUT
ABOUT THIS, LEO, I WANT YOUR
REACTION.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THE FACTS OF THIS CASE AS
PRESENTED BY THE MEDIA INDICATE
A WILLFUL ATTEMPT TO OBSTRUCT
THE WORK OF A FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL.
AND THAT IS IN AN APPROPRIATE
ROLE FOR A JUDGE.
>> Laura: NOW I GUESS JUDGE
SHELLEY HAS NOT BEEN ON THE
BENCH VERY LONG.
NEVERTHELESS, LEO, WOULD YOU
SAY, JUDGE JOSEPH, WOULD YOU SAY
THIS IS WARRANTED?
IS THIS EXTRAJUDICIAL CONDUCT?
I MEAN, WHEN YOU LOOK UP
ACTIVIST JUDGE, THIS IS REALLY
ACTIVIST JUDGE.
THIS IS NOT JUST A RULING, THIS
IS "GO."
>> WELL, LAURA, HI, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
FIRST OF ALL, GOING AFTER THE
JUDGE, WHAT ABOUT THE PROSECUTOR
AND THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY AND THE
OFFICERS WHO ALLOWED HIM OUT?
TO
ESCAPE?
I FIND THIS REALLY ODD BECAUSE,
AS THE GOVERNOR SAID, BASED ON
THE FACTS FROM THE PUBLIC, WHERE
IS THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND THE
PROSECUTOR?
WASN'T THERE A CONSPIRACY WHEN
THEY ALL GOT BEFORE THE JUDGE
AND TO SET THINGS?
SO I THINK MY COLLEAGUE, WHO IS
ON THE SHOW, IS IGNORING THE
PROSECUTOR WHO REPRESENTS THE
STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS, AND THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEY.
WHY SINGLE OUT THE JUDGE?
WHY?
I'M CONFUSED.
ONE OTHER POINT --
>> Laura: IS A JUDGE NOT HAVE
CONTROL OF THEIR OWN COURT?
BRIAN?
>> I THINK PEOPLE EXPECT A JUDGE
TO UPHOLD THE LAW, INTERPRET THE
LAW, WITHOUT SUPPORT THE LAW.
I THINK THE FOCUS IS ON THE
JUDGE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A BIZARRE SET OF FACTS.
THAT IS WHY I THINK THE JUDGES
UNDER INVESTIGATION.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE GRAND
JURY WILL FIND, APPARENTLY COME
ACCORDING TO "THE BOSTON GLOBE,"
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING, THEY ARE
HEARING DIFFERENT WITNESSES.
WHO KNOWS WHERE IT WILL LEAD.
THIS IS NOT WHAT --
>> ARE YOU ON NATIONAL TV SAYING
THAT IT WAS JUST THE JUDGE AND
NOBODY ELSE?
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I DO, BEING
A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR, THAT THERE
HAVE GOT TO BE SOME EVIDENCE
WHERE THE JUDGE ACTIVELY
INSTRUCTED SOMEONE, AND YOU ARE
JUST SPECULATING RIGHT NOW.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
THERE IS EVIDENCE ON THE RECORD
WHERE SHE SAYS, "I.C.E. IS GOING
TO GET HIM," AND THEN, IN
VIOLATION OF THE COURT RULES,
SHE TURNS OFF THE TAPE RECORDER.
SHE DOESN'T TURN OFF THE TAPE
RECORDER BECAUSE SHE IS OBEYING
THE COURT RULES.
SHE KNOWS THAT SHE'S DOING
SOMETHING, IT SEEMS, THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW, THE
DEFENDANT, AN ILLEGAL ALIEN, IS
RUNNING OUT THE BACK DOOR INTO
THE STREETS OF BOSTON.
>> Laura: HE KNEW WHAT HE WAS
GETTING.
HE WAS GETTING A GET OUT OF --
LITERALLY GETTING A GET OUT OF
DEPORTATION FREE CARD.
OKAY?
THAT IS WHAT HE WAS GETTING.
>> BRIAN AND LAURA, WHAT
ABOUT -- GET THE PROSECUTOR ON
THE "LAURA INGRAHAM SHOW," THE
PROSECUTOR AND THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY" >> Laura: LEO, I
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY B
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY O
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY E
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY ,
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY A
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY D
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY E
LOVE YOU, IF YOU WANT TO BE MY W
WILL NOT BE HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
CAN WE DO SAY THAT?
WILL ALWAYS TAKE BOOKING HELP.
I LOVE THAT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, IN
MASSACHUSETTS, WE HAVE AT LEAST
SOME OF THE COUNTIES ARE
SANCTUARY COUNTIES.
BOSTON ITSELF IS A SANCTUARY
CITY, CORRECT?
SO THIS IS KIND OF IN THE DNA
NOW OF BOSTON, THAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO RELEASE PEOPLE OUT THE
FRONT DOOR OF THE COURTROOM
BECAUSE I.C.E. IS GOING TO, ON
OCCASION, WE HELP MORE THAN ON
OCCASION, BE THERE, TO ARREST
THEM ONCE THEY ARE RELEASED.
AND THEY'D ALL THAT, THAT IS WHY
THEY GO OUT THE BACK DOOR.
SNEAK OUT THE BOX.
>> I GUESS WE NOW HAVE SANCTUARY
COURTROOMS.
>> Laura: CODE POINT.
>> BASED ON THIS, IF YOU ARE
HAVING A SANCTUARY CITY, YOU
HAVE JUST STATED THAT EVERY
OFFICIAL WHO ENDORSED A
STATE-SPONSORED SANCTUARY CITY
SHOULD BE ARRESTED FOR FAILING
TO COOPERATE WITH I.C.E.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE BASICALLY
SAYING.